[Music]
since metabolism underlies you know
pretty much the way we live where any
organism lives because it is the way
energy and resources are being supplied
to cells and and so forth here you can
determine calculate many things about
organisms about their growth patterns
how they grow how long they take and
mature and in particular one that
concerns many of us and that is how long
we live you know what determines our
longevity and in fact that's what got me
into this work originally was I became
very intrigued in my fifties about the
phenomenon of aging and of dying that I
became again Kant became more and more
conscious that things have been changing
in my life in terms of my body and my
physiology and that you know already I'd
had friends died and so I became
intrigued as to what is that and I also
became intrigued very much as a
physicist not asking what is the
mechanism and the systematics about
aging and mortality but the very
question what determines a hundred years
for the lifespan of human being why is
it a ruffler of order 100 years not a
thousand years or million years and and
and also related to that why is it that
a mouse which you know is made of pretty
much the same stuff as we are we were
almost identical really and some you
know kind of coarse-grained level
looking at things how come mouse only
institute of three years so what is
determining all this and if you have
this theory of networks underlying these
scaling laws manifesting themselves of
scaling laws you first ask you know is
there a scaling law for lifespan you
know so
this is work that had already been done
by many people was to look at lifespan
as a function of size for a bunch of
mammals in particular but organisms in
general just as we looked at you know
how metabolic rate scales across these
animals and what was discovered what had
been discovered was that lifespan also
increases following these quarter power
scaling laws that it increased
systematically the one difference by the
way and maybe I'll say a few words about
this in a moment is that there's much
more scatter among the data for lifespan
compared to things like metabolic rates
so even though there is a kind of
predictability that is you give me the
size of a mammal I will tell you on the
average how long that mammal will live
there's much more variance around that
number than there is for saying you suck
tell me the size of a mammal I will tell
you what its metabolic rate is what the
length of its aorta is how many children
it should have and so on where there's
much less variance very much tighter
lifespan has much more variance now what
so but where does that number come from
so you have this theory that the scaling
and metabolic rate and these many other
quantities and by the way there's
probably 50 or 75 such measurable
quantities these are determined by the
constraints of flows in networks such as
the surgery system so one of the things
you immediately realize about those
flows is that they are what we call
dissipative which simply means they
involve wear and tear just as you know
outside in those streets outside this
building there's a lot of traffic going
back and forth on the roads and those
roads wear out they have to be repaired
the railways have to be repaired and the
subways have to be repaired they wear
out from
the traffic so to speak and so it is the
traffic throughout multiple network
systems produced wear and tear and the
most damaging wear and tear occurs at
the terminal units the terminal points
of these networks because they're the
smallest tubes like anti capillaries or
within ourselves and pushing fluid
pushing blood corpuscles or whatever it
is big molecules through them has
deleterious effects your various kinds
that causes damage and that damage is
calculable because you have a theory
there is telling you what the flow rates
and so on and all the sizes are and so
on of this so these are calculable so
you can calculate the rate of which wear
and tear is occurring and you can also
calculate something else that is going
on and that is while it's being damaged
there's also repair going on and we do
repair ourselves but that repair is also
determined by metabolism that's where
the energy comes from to do repair so
you can determine all these things and
then you can postulate that the system
will become non viable that is it can no
longer be sustained when a given
fraction of unrepaired damages occur so
the system eventually just cannot be
sustained and so that gives you a
calculation of maximum lifespan you know
this is the you know if you were to do
the best you possibly could this is as
long as you could possibly live for a
given size of mammal and if you do that
you can understand where roughly
speaking this hundred years for a human
being comes from but more importantly or
equally importantly you can determine
what the parameters are the knobs that
you could conceivably turn to change
that lifespan what could you do
to make that go from 100 to 200 for
example and there's two pieces of that
one is you could decrease of course the
wear and tear or you can increase the
repair so those are the two obvious
things and there are parameters that
determine that so if you think about the
damage that is occurring from metabolism
so that means okay one way we could
there decrease damage is decrease the
amount of food we take it okay that
would be one way and indeed by the way
the reason a large animal lives longer
than a small one is because the
metabolic rate per unit mass or per cell
gets systematically smaller the bigger
the animal corresponding to these
quarter power scaling oils so less
damage is done at the cellular level the
bigger the animal in a systematic way so
the question is how do you decrease that
even further
one is you can eat less and that's
called caloric restriction so if you you
know put yourself on a starvation diet
you know it may not be so pleasant in
terms of your lifestyle but you know
this would predict that you live longer
and then experiments done on mice in
particular in some of monkeys most of
which show an effect this effect and the
effect is calculable in this theory and
many of the experiments done on that
agree with the the data that's been
taken on mice there have been some
controversial experiments on monkeys
which have not shown as big an effect so
this is still very much work in progress
but there's another way you could also
decrease your metabolism and that's a
way that is very difficult for us but
interestingly is very easy
almost all other organisms on this
planet and that's to do with the fact
that we are unique in that we are what's
called homeo terms namely we keep the
same temperature the body we discovered
this extraordinary mechanism of keeping
our body temperatures constant that is
fantastic because it dissociates us from
the external temperature the
environmental temperature everything
else is subject to the ambient
temperature in their environment and
here's why it matters is because
metabolic rate is derived from chemical
reactions and chemical reactions depend
exponentially on external temperature on
the temperature which they are operating
that means a small change in temperature
can have a huge effect so small change
of temperature small increase in
temperature increases your metabolic
rate exponentially so that's why you
know if you look at insects in in the
cold when they're cold in the morning
they can barely move they have to wait
till the Sun comes up to warm themselves
and then they can start flying around
and moving around and so on that's true
lizards and so on essentially everything
that's around us we are immune from that
and that's been extraordinarily
tremendous advantage going back to
lifespan that means that if you could
lower your body temperature you would
decrease your metabolic rate and you
would decrease therefore the damage and
you can live longer and that isn't true
indeed true of organisms that all other
organisms if you keep them at low
temperatures they live exponentially
longer they live much longer so it's a
fantastic effect it's a huge effect and
by the way one tangential remark to that
and that is a critical one in our times
and that is to do with global warming
that you know one of the things that you
know I think it's a bit mysterious to
many people in the you know kind of the
intelligent layperson is that why should
one or two degrees change in the ambient
temperature around us make any bloody
difference to anything after all where I
live the temperature often changes by 40
degrees you know from from night today
so you know we have these huge changes
yet the ambient you know just this
little big increase in the amp in the
average temperature has such a big
effect the reason is that things like
growth rates and death rates and
everything to do with growing and
therefore agriculture but the whole
ecosystem whole biosphere is
exponentially sensitive to a change in
temperature so one to two degrees change
has an exponential effect and some of
that is found from our viewpoint highly
deleterious and some may actually be
advantageous but I think this is an
incredibly important point that I'm
afraid I'm a little bit critical here my
colleagues who work in global warming
they have not been very good getting
this across you know especially
obviously to politicians and especially
of course the politicians in the United
States but going back to the more
parochial issue of lifespan if we were
to lower if we were to take drugs that
could lower our body temperature and
this has actually been done for mice
again it increases concomitant Lee their
lifespan decrease that metabolic rate
increases their lifespan and that's been
seen and it is an agreement with the
theoretical predictions
[Music]